ernst zu meinen heutigen video läuft ihr
seht schon dem titel mein baby die face
app erinnert euch vielleicht dann videos
wie dieses hier oder dieses hier hat es
geschafft gibt einen eigenen hype um
diese app und ihr werden heute testen
wir das sind ich und sebastian konnte
das brauchen wir werden heute einige
youtuber und bekannte persönlichkeit und
in diese fächer reinwerfen und gucken
wie die leute sind 40 50 jahren aussehen
werden haben wir so ähnlich schon mal
gemacht haben wir das durcheinander
gemischt dass so ein bus ist dass mir
das video schnell auf ja das kann keine
komplette behinderung auf ihn zu hören
michael ist für peter aus man macht es
dinge auch nur einen deut industry
studiert man kommt auf seine entdeckung
texte die in altenoythe - überwand die
app mit der man das machen kann heißt
face und führt sein gestartet wird mit
dem ersten foto ich habe mir hier ein
foto von sascha rausgesucht und bei dem
interessierte sich tatsächlich sehr
falls ich find auch der plötzlich so
groß ist die app hat irgendwie ein
krasses update bekommen und jetzt ist
das so richtig heftig wenn man diese
effekte anwendet und bei sascha kann ich
mir gar nicht vorstellen wieder aussieht
in elters du genau dort also ich klicke
auf den filter alt und dies wirklich
viel größer geworden oh mein gott oder
mama wann gehst wie heftig ist dass die
falten an den augen und sauber gemacht
und die feuerwalze
das echt nicht stellt also es ist es
besser als frau aber die kärntner älter
geworden dass sich die tiere haben da
oben sind auch die daraus folgenden auch
viel dünner geworden
sascha wäre wenn man sich so anschaut
auf jeden fall eine attraktive silver
age müssen was für
das will ich unbedingt mit einer für den
spruch gerade aber weiter da schon okay
diese person wer auch nicht ständig in
seiner zusammenstellung immer dann in
wien weil irgendwie so ein youtube
personelle kommen wir mal noch dabei als
alte frau aussieht
okay das ist ein bisschen irritierend
weil es bezieht sich nur auf das gesicht
und die rechtlich ausgleich aber das ist
so ein bisschen richtung heidi klum wie
oder wo also alles hat die kurve ist
wenn sie wirklich so aussieht wenn sie
alt bist ja nicht was auch kamera oder
das schon wird gegenüberstellung ich
will dieser weise der fed ist schon
gratis ellerich bekommen wahrscheinlich
noch nie sagen aber die ernte nicht so
mehr eines bella ja das ist aber auch
der ton vielleicht ein bisschen theater
bleibt das gesicht ein bisschen älter
und reifer aussieht aber irgendwann ist
er also ist das schon ein bisschen ihre
zwei gesichter das ist nämlich monte mit
seiner oma unternehmen manches gesicht
machen einen alten vielleicht sind ja
dann auch als rennfahrer eigentliche
aber macht macht erstmal auf die oma
drauf und ich mache meine jugend mit man
seit 1906 ist eva krause waren sie da
oben drauf gemacht oder so was hat er
schon so krank alter die haut am hals
und so die haut so viel roter das ist
wahrscheinlich so werden ja schon heftig
das besitzerehepaar werdet ihr
operatives free
die zeit des bürgerkriegs kleingeld
jetzt haben wir das ganze noch mal
machen der montessori displays der ein
krasses updater der faces alles perfekt
er wolle nicht dass das nur die alters
funktionen gefeiert wird sich dies so
gut geht direkt weiter wir haben unseren
guten freund michael ouzas besser
bescheid des kriegs wahrscheinlich
irgendwie ist es ja nicht dass das jetzt
mal an wie micky in 40 jahren aussieht
dann ist ein um
ich hoffe nur es abgeschaltet wenn das
hier doch dies wird dann kriegst du auch
was hast du getan kann kommt man seine
einkommen mehr heraus auf der hand hält
ist ja die haut faltig und transparenter
und dabei herzen da sein haus richtig
und point und trotzdem kriegt die apps
hin dass diese so krass aussieht heftig
ich finde meine sieht er aus wie sowieso
eine modeikone ja wieso jemand der sein
milliarden imperium mit mode selbst
genauso behälter und nichts dagegen also
vielleicht doch nicht so schlimm wie im
bild hat mir gleich drei kandidaten du
darfst gerne jemanden aussuchen bei
denen wir den check machen
ich glaube machen der alterskategorie
ich will mal sehen ob ich auch das
make-up bekommt crazy ist jetzt auch für
die haut würden brüsten und so verändert
hat dass die fahrer vor ihm schmid
verhindert
mein gott das ist so heftig ohne mit
dieser erweiterung der aber letztlich
habe man keine wunder dass grasser hat
es funktioniert einfach sieht aber auch
wirklich angsteinflößend auch davon
sagen oder das sieht so aus
was ich aber aus wie seine besitzerin
die sich seit 20 jahren so innerem in
seine männer besetzten markt so
durchgeschlagen hat und eine bibel
abgebrüht ist kein geld da ok jetzt bin
ich richtig gespannt wie sie mit blauen
haaren macht die app jahren grau oder
sowas wäre ich glaube manchmal gehört
dass auch dazu wir testen ist einfach
mal irgendwie so hier den alters filter
heftig wieso sieht aus wie jemand aus
der cdu gegen den schuss das ist jetzt
also dass die alterung ist wieder druck
gemacht aber das sieht super traurig aus
oder was ist mit der pose dieser pause
so für diese laune habe der als pate
perfekt dieter bohlen co ja wir wollen
diese krise wird offiziell aussehen wie
dieter bohlen
also ist habe ich schon weit vor so
einem tisch mit schönen garten flori
korso firma zu mein kompass und mädchen
gaben an dass der algorithmus ist so
schlau der antizipiert die schönheits op
habe ich auch gemacht
ja das ist dabei auch das ist schon
alles hier dass er gar nicht so der
direkt das bild hat doch schon bald aber
liegt aber wir haben halt schon aber
jetzt hat auch ein gesicht einfach
überhaupt keine ansatzpunkte der filter
einsetzt oder z alles klar
als nächstes erwarten würde ich sagen
wir mal ein bild von uns beiden
wen von uns treffen was sagst du richtig
erkennt solche aussiehst du siehst aus
wie jemand wer dabei auf eine apotheken
werbung oder für eine versicherung ist
ach du scheiße erhalten ist ein bisschen
verkrüppelt junge das heißt sich nach
tumor aus der tür das passiert bei der
heizung bibel aber nichtsdestotrotz der
ja aber du siehst wie vor genauso aus
wie so jemand der seine blaue apotheken
rundschau auf dem karl will irgendwann
mir das eigentlich weiß ich was mir das
angst dass zu sehen ich würde zu sehen
ich weiß dass man einander los ist wenn
es um sich selbst sehen aber ich will ja
ich könnte gleich ob das für mich auch
dass michael sich das ist nicht geil
also wenn wir das so anders redet und
das hat aber dass selbst die seghers ist
oder warum werden meine haare graue von
fast niemand und die haare graue wände
grau lila aber wenn ich jetzt mal die
mundpartie also sagen wir mal nur so die
den kiefer die backen und sowas
betrachtet empfinde ich geht das
irgendwie so ein bisschen richtung von
papa okay als wir die die hautalterung
ich sehe ist und ich sehe dass ein
bisschen könnte das musik aber ich meine
es macht uns ist macht ein jahr älter
als unser vater ist
obwohl und natürlich sehr sehr jung
aussieht und sehr gute
und weil es ist und sich das geld aber
nichtsdestotrotz das ist schon heftig
gut gemacht ich habe noch eine kleine
auswahl wird sagen wir machen das ganz
einfach mal mit diana das könnte gut
funktionieren weil sie auf dem foto was
wir ausgewählt hat schon weiße haare
das aus ist natürlich auch sehr rennen
wirklich nicht aber irgendwas jetzt hat
schon etwas irritieren so ist die zahl
heute trifft oder oberlehrers somit
gehört wenn wir das nicht auch dieses
jahr und auch sozial könnte schon sein
dass sie dass er irgendwann mal wichtig
sind das ist schon heftig muss man sagen
passen passen als ausländer also kaum
machen
ja das wird dann so aussehen passt
wir sind auch schon fast am ende
angekommen gucken wir uns einfach mal zu
ihm okay bob was peter winter wird es
natürlich auch perfekt
es sieht einfach genauso aus aber hat
das ja man sagt also black tomb raider
das alte doch er war als junge leute
nicht alt aussehen aber das ist ja -
genommen hast das gefühl ja ich habe
auch als auch bei asiaten also was ist
sondern
somit ist oder so kann man sieht schon
dass cage auf jeden fall bis auf diesem
weg sind so karatemeister der aber auch
so
ja genau das schon heftiger also motor
der mich so viel besser geworden das ist
richtig kann und ich muss sagen wenn man
alle leute die bisher in diesem video
bahn nicht mal ausnahmsweise jetzt
gemeinde etwas über sich selbst gesagt
die schönste altersheim deutschland da
kommt es sehr schön zu deutschland das
altersheim youtuber machen geschäftsidee
des dortigen ist die häufigste sagte
youtube das helfen und zu guter letzt
hier ein foto von callie ich bin
gespannt ich finde so ihre haut ist so
richtig es oft so dass auf dem bild des
haltungs peter drauf wer kann sonst bei
kelly kann nicht mehr richtig schwer an
george sehr gut vorstellen logo es
aussieht das sieht aus wie die ex
freundin von bastian schweinsteiger
sarah brandner aber so will ich alles
wie die aussehen ich finde das sieht aus
wie eine frau die das regierungs oder
auch verstehen ist es kann gut sein er
wählen so ein bisschen junge leute kenne
sieht auch nicht richtig alt aus damit
oder so eine so eine deutsche erste oder
sowas ja genau die porsche fährt aber es
ist stabil
du bist nicht davon gekommen weil ich
sie wirklich viel jünger aus
damit kritisierte zwar die regie weniger
deutet falten und so dass ich hoffe es
hat euch zu sagen was gern leicht da
schreiben wir die kommentare mit wem ich
das auch machen muss vielleicht mal wenn
man zweites video ansonsten vielleicht
auf instagram deshalb könnt ihr auch
gerne folgen des anschlags
sebastian ist natürlich in einem steilen
verlinken wir sehen uns dann macht's gut